your brothers and sisters in islam net
from norway are establishing a masjid a
daowa center
this center this masjid this educational
institution will act like a beacon of
light calling the muslims in norway back
to the essence of islam so give
generously and allah azzawajal will give
you even more
yeah
all right
we're here in wonderful leicester where
it's not been wonderful has it brother
tell me what's happening you tell me
what's happening
who wants to tell me what's happening
coming to the video
you don't know what's happened
okay now no recently i don't know
basically go ahead please
extremist hindu group
came to leicester yesterday yeah a lot
of them were from out of town not many
more from local decided to vandalize
leicester
uh attack muslims and we're just here
we're going to show them that we're not
going to stand for this we're going to
peacefully we're going to peacefully
protest
but we also need to show them that we're
not scared of them
so we're going to go in this direction
and we're going to peacefully protest
that's right
again they've not turned up today what
can you tell us some of the stuff that's
happened because people around the world
hundreds of thousands of people are
going to be watching this video right
now they want to know basically what's
happened go ahead for the past six
months they've come around mosque
vandalizing mosques
just causing hating our brothers or
sisters just attacking them
but have you started on them no we've
not started on them you've given them
chances you said trust allah there it be
so why are you doing this why did this
some people ask
we gave them a chance a week later uh
one of the brother got attacked
how did he get attacked how bad was it
there was 30 people
30 people attacked one brother you've
got a bruised yeah
not hindus hindu and i tell everyone
that's watching it to read upon the rss
ideology which comes from the ideal
ideology of hitler so i advise everyone
to read upon that because that's the
same ideology that's running in
leicester now we've never had problems
we've never had issues
we've never had issues with hindus we've
lived peacefully we've had neighbors
we've even helped them in the country
it's a part of hindus that are coming in
today
so everything that's happened has
happened from their side we've stood up
are we saying here that these and good
for individuals who are inspired by this
ideology are simply attacking muslims
because they are muslim
exactly that and that's the same thing
if you read upon it that's the exact
same thing that happens in india and if
you read up on some of the stories it's
horrible the way that they go about
their the way that they go about is they
go out in mobs
they ask are you muslim and then what
they do they strip you
and they beat you up there in public and
kill you basically they're trying to
bring that that's the ideology and
that's coming
opportunities yeah to keep it peaceful
yeah they've gone out
spreading our word but they've still not
done that yesterday they came down 200
people from london to the coach and
they've come down
apparently they're supposed to have a
peaceful
watch a protest but they started
vandalizing everything just kicking off
breaking cars hitting people mostly my
brothers by the way i'm escorted by the
police as well and now we're trying to
do the same thing today as this brother
knows he was here as well yeah they're
trying to do the same thing but please
are stopping us from doing that
right yes so
so what i'm going to say is this can can
we all agree on something that
people unless i've had enough now yes or
no
yeah yeah people are here unless i've
had enough of this islamophobia that's
going on is that right yeah yes
and if someone gets hit or attacked are
we gonna
stick up for our brothers muslims
just walking around peacefully
but now the circumstances have changed
because we've walked around peacefully
for one and a half miles without their
presence
yeah yeah but two hours ago yeah they
didn't know why did they use for raging
because they didn't let us watch but now
they're letting us march
and you know what he said to him
you guys said we've got police presence
now they heard that from day one why
didn't there's march two hours later
we're back to square what you're saying
is that you feel like you've been
treated fairly
without anything
[Music]
no matter what we do no matter what we
do we're still terrorists
one thing i want to say is this people
that are not aware of what's going on in
india people need to realize that people
are getting people are getting killed
because they because they've slaughtered
a cow to eat beef yeah that's what's
happening now that might sound
ridiculous to you like you know most of
us are meat eaters
these vicious
number one is what to raise awareness
not just what's happening here in
leicester and that this radical ideology
and whatever has come in but
also in india
because it all
emanates whether yes
the second object the second objective
is to defend ourselves
give them double cheek within the law of
islam will win the british law that you
can use uh proportional force yes
reasonable force so what i'm going to
say is this is that
enough is enough yeah we're not going to
have this anymore at the end of the day
if you want to try and bring fascism in
the form of hindu fashion of the uk it's
going to get squashed quite quickly
your brothers and sisters in the slam
net from norway are establishing a
masjid a daowa center
this center this masjid this educational
institution will act like a beacon of
light calling the muslims in norway back
to the essence of islam so give
generously and allah will give you even
more